this is homer my son
and heisha's son pays tribute to the
late actress
anne died on friday a week after driving
her car into a house sparking an
explosion
ann was in a coma before being
pronounced brain dead she was 53 years
old after news of anne's death broke her
20-year-old son homer shared this
statement with e.t
my brother atlas and i lost our mom
after six days of almost unbelievable
emotional swings i am left with a deep
wordless sadness
and suffered a severe and toxic brain
injury as a result of the crash which
left her legally dead her heart is said
to still be beating though we're told
she was put on life support as the
family waits to find out which of her
organs are viable
as anne's rep tells e.t it has long been
her choice to donate her organs i
decided i'm going to be the best mom
oh that was a cute
i know you you are oh
in the days following the accident a
source told e.t homer was taking the
lead in making decisions for his mom's
care in his statement homer says he
hopes his late mom is free from pain and
exploring what it's like to have eternal
freedom
many others joined homer in
memorializing anne on friday the father
of her second child 13 year old atlas
actor james tupper posted to instagram
simply writing love you forever with a
heartbreak emoji
then there's ellen degeneres whom ann
dated for more than three years in the
late 90s the comedian paid tribute
writing this is a sad day i'm sending
anne's children family and friends all
of my love i think people have let go of
this a little bit i think they've calmed
down and realized that you know it's
just uh
hopefully something that's just like
anybody any other couple
ellen and ann were trailblazers when it
came to loving out loud and proud and in
2020 the actress reflected on their
contributions to lgbtq history we went
through an incredible time and we were
part of truly a part of a revolution
that helped move the needle and i'm and
i couldn't be more grateful for that
it's a message anne's rep echoes
speaking to her legacy quote her bravery
for always standing in her truth
spreading her message of love and
acceptance will continue to have a
lasting impact
love is a choice and i made one and it
was one of the most life-changing
choices
of my life
and will also live on in her work she
still has projects to be released
including a lifetime film out next month
she's a firecracker she had a passion
for stopping violence against women as
especially she had a passion for working
with lifetime because she felt that
lifetime was responsible
around movies such as this all of this
anne was a part of she was committed to
that
and she like larissa and you said she
came to work with the tremendous passion
towards getting this film out there and
making a big impact
you